los chicos cool se preocupan por el
cambio climático Afirma esta pancarta en
Indonesia jóvenes y activistas
medioambientales marcharon para
denunciar la inacción climática con un
ecosistema ya amenazado por la minería
la industria madera y las plantaciones
masivas de Palma aceitera los
manifestantes estimen las consecuencias
para el archipiélago
las zonas más afectadas por las
catástrofes naturales eran más
castigadas como en la costa norte de la
isla de Java mientras que las zonas
boscosas están desapareciendo hay más
incendios forestales más ciclones
tropicales y al final no será solo una
crisis económica sino también
humanitaria
los reclamos escucharon también bajo la
lluvia de Australia si bien el nuevo
gobierno laborista ha prometido reducir
un 43% de las emisiones de gases de
efecto invernadero de aquí a 2030
cientos de estudiantes faltaron a clase
para exigir que no se aprueben más
proyectos de Carbón petróleo y gas ya
que los jóvenes de todo el país y de
todo el mundo están preocupados porque
nuestro futuro está en peligro así que
por eso hemos venido aquí para enviar un
mensaje muy claro a nuestro gobierno a
nuestros líderes y a las empresas de
todo el mundo de que ya es suficiente y
que necesitamos que se produzca un
cambio
en Italia Alemania y Austria los
manifestantes hicieron el mismo llamado
actuar ahora
escasez de alimentos y de agua potable
subida del nivel del mar algunos de esos
efectos del cambio climático ya son
irreversibles los científicos al igual
que los activistas ecológicos señalan la
falta de voluntad política para frenar
esta crisis que hará inhabitables zonas
enteras de nuestro planeta